comedy homicidal TV live at the dope
spot we are live here in Denver at
native roots apothecary apothecary
is a Spanish word that means place you
can get we legally and do okay this is
Graham right here man telling us about
some of the product so so Agent Orange
you haven't tried it yet
have a try but when you're in Denver you
paranoid crisis yeah so now I'm serious
so this is what is the HP hydrant
best of both worlds sativa and indica my
grandma's here
yeah cuz we use this when you buy weed
from somebody's like is weed yeah this
is good let's talk about some of the
other products damn natural sensual
dance malaria designed for female
pleasure is this a popular product it
it's becoming one of our most popular
what we manufacture it now so you can
only get for you exclusive was the best
orgasm she's ever had in her life BAM
yeah that my gosh
orgasms go what did the guys feel
annoyed so the guy Oliver
it's not about delay satisfied no one
if--and oil there's a life together
tormented you got a final statement is
for a dog-and-pony this is what Tony had
Tony I put patches this is the game
changer here because there are some
people that don't want to get a medical
card but still want therapeutic benefits
yeah grab which one of those patches
make you yell about the movie Birdman
it's one minute because that's what Tony
is one of those laced with cocaine is it
a bad batch because somebody was
screaming about hating the movie Birdman
what is this right here man what we may
cause euphoria or hearted sense of
reality and a punch is we juice man
that's what they doing out here in
Colorado weed juice they make it you
know that's what happens when stuff is
legal you can experiment see what works
out there's no music weed steaks and
[ __ ] we vodka oh [ __ ] yeah sweet infused
vodka
yes see my mother [ __ ] adjust that's
what it happens people get high and then
they get put weed and stuff bedtime weed
infused chicken noodle soup
what does that mean what is like the
intoxicated effects of this product may
be delayed by two or more hours she does
have one thing edibles and drink is that
we right there don't sneak out home
unless we candy there's a Sour Patch Kid
or the South has careful a week you
don't know TSA lady I'll eat it right in
front of you they know [ __ ] the top two
values they know their business precise
intelligence care to care about their
product they know everything and it's
cool dribbles small bubbles lube and
t-shirts good for them good business I
was that got in early
[Music]
while out at the dispensary smoking cut
to a video of mystical smoke this feels
great mystical has some of the greatest
smoking songs in